after the game where it could have swung
a different way that he was involved
yeah I mean I've trusted in KT
um he missed a lot of training camp
um obviously he wanted to play and
thought Rehab Hard so he could play
um and and stuff's not always going to
go your way obviously
um he wouldn't want to catch a few of
those in the game but I've trusted he's
going to be that guy that I go to in
those crucial moments and he's gonna
make the catch and and and and win us
some Seasons like he did last year so
we're going to continue to work him in
getting more and more reps and I'm sure
that those drops will kind of disappear
what's the message it needs to come out
of that locker room got to be better
all right thank you